i don't i've heard things you've said in
the back hey
and i want you to know that you can say
things in that luscious buttery voice
all you want
listen
it feels like
just a little bead of maple syrup going
down a tree just just because i called
you a big lovable hedgehog does not mean
a big lovable [ __ ] hedgehog are you
kidding me
you're like sonic but like gross well
like i said when i called you a big
lovable hedgehog i wasn't being mean and
you just gotta keep saying it yeah
can you can you put it in a way to where
you don't have to say that but it's like
it's one word that just sums it all up
um
beautiful
okay dude [ __ ] you
that's like some lifetime network for
women [ __ ] where it's like the the
husband's just beating the [ __ ] out of
his wife the whole movie but he's like
you know you're beautiful right yeah
my dad my dad is a very southern man
that i mean he would get uh
drunk a lot and pass out and have dip in
his mouth and be snoring on the couch
but he'd always watch lifetime oh okay
that was that's a violent channel
uh
you watch it i don't think i have
meredith baxter berniean
leaving february it's just her getting
the [ __ ] beat out of her the whole time
really that's every one of those movies
i'm not even joking really it's crazy
and for some reason they're like women
are going to love this
my dad just sit there watching the whole
time yeah he's just like no emotions on
his face
[Laughter]
hey dad we're eating spaghetti tonight
yeah and the data's just going into his
brain but he has no clue what he's
processing
you could have put you know it's
actually so this is really really funny
this is so [ __ ] stupid such a dumb
ass he sat there and he was like uh
we were watching mighty joe young yeah
you ever see that movie it's disney's
king kong basically yeah yeah you guys
are seeing my young
okay what's an old giant girl he's a
giant gorilla
obviously
like a puppet yeah and we're watching it
on vhs yeah there you go mighty joe
young
look at that thing yeah you as a infant
i was like that is not a real yeah
monkey yeah my dad comes in and said
damn
how'd they get that gorilla to do all
that
that was like
[Laughter]
i've never seen so much like
disappointment in like my mom about
being like damn that's who i chose
[Laughter]
yeah i mean
but to hear you're growing [ __ ] that
damn
damn that
how'd they
how'd they get him to do that
is it like uh they must unionize like a
carnival or something to
hire that i'm like
it's a it's like a robot
and my mom was like so disappointed she
was like do you think jurassic park is
real
it gets like all offended and [ __ ] you
know god damn no i i know them as robots
[Laughter]
oh my [ __ ] god can you google me the
uh the cover of the v8 like if you type
in mighty young vhs dude the cover of
the vhs is so funny
that it's like
and like we would prob like you know you
had your vhs collection and it would
just like you'd put the case of the
movie or whatever
yeah yeah literally look at that look at
that yeah
my dad's like god damn
they're trying they're training chimps
now
you know we used to send them to space
but look at him he's he's [ __ ] just
going to work and like
damn i've never seen a grown man so
excited
there's so that's an insult just
just telling us
it's amazing what they got these monkeys
doing now man they got them doing whole
movies the movie is called mighty joe
young
i just want to
and like look at the bottom right of
those of the humans they put it's just
like jpeg or like pngs
yeah this giant
does that even look like a gorilla now
that i'm looking at now it just looks
like they just took a giant ball of hair
and just put it like
probably onto an animatronic i mean
they're just like
but be free mighty joe
my dad's like damn i'm getting
teary-eyed oh sorry
the [ __ ] mane
isn't that the dude from true lies look
at the cast
i swear that's the dude from true lies
who like yes
oh she was in that movie bro that's the
guy where yeah bill paxton yeah we're
dead now you know
you know uh goddamn what's her name puts
the uh lipstick to his back and he pees
his pants
okay well uh i remember
it's a remaster movie
yeah i was like it must have been some
french movie i didn't see that's all
right the uh i remember him in twister
the tornado was real my dad probably did
think that twitter he's like this guy go
watch out for them
he wants to say you should say damn you
know what helen hunts in that
documentary
yeah
[Laughter]
bro i'm trying to remember the mighty
joe young scene when he's in the cage
and the kid is in there hugging up on
him what like what the context of that
scene was i just got some weird ptsd
right there i don't know i really don't
remember the movie i cannot believe
that's charlize theron i totally forgot
about that that's like kind of a
star-studded cast yeah now i want to do
a deep dive on lifetime films
it's good man never seen a lifetime
movie well now you got me in my head
that i'm
i'm just
i'm a rude person now huh
because i called you uh you want to go
this route now too see now you're trying
to be self-aware and trying to get out
of it no i'm not trying to get out of it
i'll catch you dude this is i see right
through you this is
your you're a window and i'm i'm peeking
through what do you see
a handsome man
[Laughter]
just just lining it up like you're gonna
be rude as [ __ ] yeah exactly and see i
take the high road yeah sort of that's
what i do yeah so then now
the viewer you're probably wondering why
you like me the most in this situation
and that's why
psychology 101 i took a couple classes
and called it i didn't i did
i took art history yeah what'd you learn
hi road hunter yep tell us i rode high
road hancock
it's my last name
do you know me that well my last name is
hancock i just
okay i don't know how comfortable you
were with
yeah like distributing that information
well you can google it
or you can just ask you know i still use
ask jeeves
get the [ __ ] out of here i'm not even
joking
just because to be funny yeah you
because we're hanging out you're telling
me stuff that you do and i was just
laughing i'm like
you approach life like like a comedy and
more people need to do that i need to do
that you made me realize how serious i
take life and i'm a [ __ ] idiot the
whole [ __ ] you were talking about like
faking phone calls that was so goddamn
funny
yeah this is hilarious
ask jeeves yeah good website
i endorse
jeeves ask jeeves
how much
is a cheeseburger at red robin you know
what i think he's gonna say things and
say depending on what it is yeah if it's
if it's the southwest
crispy onion burger i'm gonna guess it's
about 9.99
if i was a betting man
what does jeeves have for us here bro it
still comes back in raw text that's
amazing
what are you trying to do is is that an
insult to this site no i'm i'm serious
all right guys [ __ ] i hate how
evolved like google and [ __ ] is where
it's got 45 [ __ ] ads you can't trust
any of the results because they're all
paid for or indexed from like 20 years
ago i like that this [ __ ] is just lo-fi
you just get text back get in get out
with jeeves yeah
[ __ ] geez hire hunter man
i would i would glad i'd do it for free
if they if they literally send me a
shirt i'd probably i'd wear it in every
video i did
they have the worst logo
i've ever seen and if it was a
compressed jpeg on a shirt i would wear
it every day of my life
i would ruin my marriage over it
hold up bro do you remember when you're
going to the cheesecake factory dress up
i got my jeeps look at that look at that
bass drum no [ __ ] this
god damn what happened to the no type in
ass jeeves mascot on google
he looks you look good i bet they lost
the
probably too fancy for him now what font
is that that that is like some yeah
powerpoint font yeah papyrus something
from
areas like a little dapper boy yeah why
is that [ __ ] not on the actually that
second image is actually horrifying
the parade 3d thing is that a parade god
damn
damn
yeah my dad's like whoa
he's a big [ __ ] how's that big
boy fly like that